we have recently seen closures of steel
plants across Europe costing thousands
of jobs the steel industry faces
important immediate challenges which are
putting at risk the existence of a
significant and competitive steel
industry in Europe the council agreed on
the gravity of the situation and under
need to take actions that will ensure
the long-term viability of the European
steel sector we need to intensify
discussions involving all important
steel producers such as China Russia
Belarus turkey and india we have to
follow the law and do a thorough
investigation to ensure the right of
defence of interested parties are
respected the Commission has also
proposed to modernize trade defence
instruments and this proposal is on the
agenda or on the table of Council and
the European Parliament so we do hope
that the co legislators would good Acree
on the proposal as soon as possible
climate negotiations in Paris will have
a big impact to the market as everybody
knows cop21 will have significant impact
especially to to China's steel
production so it is probably one single
biggest decision hopefully it can be
done in Paris at the end of this month